so first of all I'd like to say refer
you if you want a written version of
parts of this talk and some other parts
that I couldn't include in it I did a
write-up of my Turing lecture in the
December issue of the C ACM and that is
on my Stanford publications page a free
pdf Thank You C ACM for making it freely
available in like some places and so you
can download it just google Stanford
Hellman publications and you should get
the publication's page or if you go to
my home page there's a link to
publications and if you want even more
just underneath that C ACM paper which i
think is number 78 and the publication's
list there are three books listed and
the third book is a book my wife and I
just completed a year and a half ago on
the subtitle describes it creating true
love at home and peace on the planet
which doesn't have much to do with CS
380 except a lot of the stories are in
there because so much of what I've
learned like I'm gonna tell you a story
today where the devil was on my shoulder
whispering in my ear that stories in
there and you might also find the other
parts interesting especial if we want to
be using public key cryptography 50 or
100 we want people to be using public
key cryptography 50 100 years from now
the creating peace on the planet parts
very important because otherwise we're
not likely to be here so there aren't
how many students are there here now
let's see raise hands Oh more great ok I
know most of you are out there on the TV
system watching this later but if you're
in the ph.d program and if you have a
moment where you think Who am I to make
an original contribution to knowledge no
you're in very good company when I was
doing my PhD here 66 to 68
I felt that I've got great made great
progress in the first nine months or a
year and then I for about six months I
was feeling you know I hit a brick wall
Who am I to make an original
contribution to knowledge and then half
an hour later after sitting those six
months and within half an hour it went
from there to almost having the thesis
done let me just do a show of hands
those of you who have done theses how
many of you had similar experiences
where you would not not necessarily half
an hour
but the part where you wondered because
that that's very unusual how many of you
had the experience of wondering whether
you were up to doing it and how many of
you actually made it through yeah same
people so remember that the goals of
this talk are several fold one is to
pull back the veil on the development of
public key cryptography and to see how
its I love that people call it
revolutionary and please don't stop
calling it that that makes makes me very
happy but at the end of this talk I hope
you'll have another attitude is why did
it take them so long there were all
these road signs almost pointing them I
mean much as you said about it didn't
doesn't quite go back to Plato but
trapdoors were known about but making
them into a public key cryptosystem was
something totally different they're all
levels of trapdoors as you'll see so the
evolutionary aspect and also to honor
some of the unsung and under some heroes
so if the ACM Turing award was given to
dit wit tiffy and me Ralph Merkle might
or might not have been included as
you'll see he's been included on some
awards or not on others he was not
included in this one but he certainly
was not unsung is under sung and then
you hear about others who you probably
never have heard of another question why
is the talk so historical well because I
don't work in this area intensively
anymore I work primarily on the risk of
nuclear war and how to reduce it and
that's where the creating peace on the
planet part comes from and so what I
have a question I called dan Bona or
someone like him and get get it answered
so I don't pretend to be current so it
was public key cryptography that's here
we go
revolutionary or evolutionary well in
one sense it was revolutionary in 1883
well Gus care coffs enunciated several
important principles for a good
cryptographic system they've been around
but he codified them and one of them was
that the general system should be
considered public whether or not you
tried to keep it secrets like in the
military you might have a piece of
hardware that you keep secret because
you don't want your energy your enemy
using it but you still should assume
it's public why because it might be
captured and it's hard
change all of the security has to reside
in the secrecy of the key that was the
important part so how can you have a
public key system it seems to violate
one of the it seems to be going back to
the Dark Ages of course we did that by
separating the key into two parts a
public part and a secret part and so all
secrecy must reside all security must
reside in the secrecy of the secret key
is the answer well how is it
evolutionary well the concept half of
the concept which is the privacy part
there's two parts there's digital
signatures and wit and I were the only
two who came up with that Ralph had
privacy and actually somewhat before us
as you'll see even though it's a paper
paper appeared after ours and three
people are GCHQ the British equivalent
of NSA came up with the same ideas if we
can believe what they say and I do tend
to believe what they say but you know
how do you believe somebody twenty years
after the fact when they say well we
knew this twenty years ago and here are
our secret papers from that time now I
don't think they would pull one on us
but still there is a question of how to
deal with this so first of all it's
important to recognize you people often
talk about diffie-hellman key exchange
in this talk you'll see why I tend to
call it diffie-hellman merkel key
exchange and this is a picture taken
about a year or two after we came up
with our results ralph merkle on the
left a young or me in the middle and
hairier and with Diffie justice areas
today those of you who know him on the
right another evolutionary aspect of
public key cryptography here you're
really starting to see these road signs
pointing us there that it took us a
while to see one thing that Witte and I
did in New Directions and as we were
working on this is our paper in 1976
that put forth the idea of public key
cryptography publicly and had what's
often called diffie-hellman key exchange
we tried to find a hierarchy of
cryptographic systems and the simplest
system was a one-way function now those
were well known the UNIX operating
system
I've been using one-way functions for
years to protect passwords and that has
a kind of trapdoors you'll see in a
minute then they were conventional what
are sometimes today called symmetric
cryptosystems that was a higher level of
Triveni as you see in a minute because
you can always turn a conventional
crypto system into a one-way function
but you can't always go in the reverse
direction the next level up is something
you may not have heard of a trapdoor
crypto system this is not a public key
cryptosystem it's it's something that
I'll described in a minute but from
there to a public key cryptosystem which
is sometimes called an asymmetric system
was a relatively small step and Witney
as you'll see had come up with the idea
of a trapdoor crypto system somewhat
before we had the idea of a public key
cryptosystem so how do you get from the
very first level a I'm sorry how do you
get from the second level which is a
conventional crypto system like AES
today the advanced encryption standard
to a one-way function that's that's
showing that conventional crypto systems
can always be turned into one-way
functions but the reverse is not always
true that's why they're higher in the
hierarchy well you put a fixed plaintext
let's see I think I've got it here where
is No
maybe I don't you've got a fixed
plaintext could just be all zeros going
in the plaintext port port I call that P
not you put X the input to the one wave
function in the key port and you take Y
the output of the one wave function out
the ciphertext port how hard is it to
compute Y from X it's easy because
that's encryption right how hard is it
to go backward from Y to X to invert the
one wave function why is that hard
because that's crypt analysis okay so
you can always turn a conventional
crypto system into a one-way function
now what is a what people all sometimes
called public key systems trapdoor
crypto systems which is actually
incorrect trapdoors are essential and
associated with all kinds of
cryptographic systems not just public
key ones in fact I sometimes describe a
trapdoor quiz problem the students here
have all experienced have experienced
trapdoor quiz problems you take the quiz
and after slaving away for an hour the
professor says okay turn your papers in
oh we have two minutes left let me give
you the answer the answers and I'll
convince you they're right and in two
minutes he or she does what took you
couldn't do in an hour was very hard for
you to do in an hour now of course you
can understand why that is
there were many paths to get to the
solution the professor who made up the
problem had a specific path in mind and
went immediately to it well now a true
trapdoor a quiz problem could be
constructed from a one-way function what
I would do is I would tell the class the
one-way function like AES that I just
had on the last slide and I would pick a
random and I tell them what P naught is
all zeros for example I would generate a
random X that I would not tell the class
I would then compute Y from X tell it to
the class and say okay now find X you
could slave away for a million years at
the end of the million years I say okay
papers in oh and in the few microseconds
left on your computer put in this X and
you'll see it produces why do you see
that I could convince you of the answer
this is closely related to a very
important problem in theoretical
computer science the P equals and P
question which I won't go into the
details but many of you will know what
I'm talking about
now what's a trapdoor cryptosystem the
trapdoor quest cryptosystem would be a
generals dream or NSA's dream or all
their foreign equivalents dream think of
a military situation I am in charge of
an army on this side and you guys are
all in the army on the other side I want
my guys to be using a crypto system that
you can't break but if it's captured and
you start using I want to be able to
break it so if I could construct a
trapdoor crypto system one where there
is secret trapdoor information built in
you know it's built in but you don't
know what the value of x is that's built
into it you can't break it but if you
start using it I can quickly break it
and you see why that would be a generals
dream well trapdoor crypto systems allow
public key exchange if I can generate we
by the way I should emphasize we never
came up with a way to generate really
good trapdoor crypto systems but if we
could then I would generate
after a cryptosystem and I would know
the secret information I would not tell
it to let's say to the whole I wouldn't
tell it to anybody but I would tell you
how the system works without the
trapdoor information I would then tell
someone in the back of the room to
please send me a message using a random
key that only she knows the message she
calls the message out to me across the
room can I recover it yes because I know
the trapdoor information I can break it
even though I don't know her key I can
recover our key I can recover the
message but the rest of you can't break
it we get privacy without any
prearrangement
and so I think he can start to see the
we this came up because we were
wondering how NBS the National Bureau of
Standards now NIST the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
was going to generate a data encryption
standard which they did in 1975 that
would let that was secure and yet that
NSA wouldn't mind having we're going to
get to that later they would ideally
like to build a trapdoor in so that if
it's used by one of our America's
adversaries NSA could break it but you
see from that to a public key
cryptosystems is a small step now public
key cryptography catch up here Witt and
I developed the concept of a public key
cryptosystem and RSA was the first
implementation of a public key
cryptosystem we in our paper we had the
concept but we didn't see how to
implement it it was one where you have a
public key and a secret key and you
could use either the public key to act
on data to encrypt it and then the
secret key to decrypt it well in that
case everybody has a public key when
howie howard cohen over there sorry we
went to high school together so I
remember him as Howie he's now Howard if
he wants to send me a message he hooks
up my public key encrypts it using my
public key can Carl recover the message
no because he doesn't know my secret key
which is needed but I can do that if I
want to sign a message and send it to
Howard
I used my secret key to sign it only I
can do that Howard can use my public key
to verify it and so can Carl who's now a
judge notice there's no privacy there
but you can get privacy I know other
than ten ocation but I won't go into
that Ralph Merkle working as an
undergraduate at Berkeley and later as a
master's student came up independently
and slightly before us with the concept
of a public exchange of information
securely and I'll have I'll show you his
proposal in just a second and the
interesting thing is what's often called
diffie-hellman key exchange is actually
a Merkle system Merkel had it what he
called what we call now a public key
distribution system was a way to
distribute keys but it couldn't actually
in cipher information you then had to
get that used the key that was
distributed using Merkel's method to
then encrypt a message in a conventional
system whereas with public key
cryptosystem that went and I had
proposed you could actually in cypher
the information directly and so
diffie-hellman is the Merkel public key
distribution system which is why I often
call it diffie-hellman Merkel so Ralph
took CS 244 in the fall of 1974 at
Berkeley and you had to do a term
project that he proposed to term
projects one was project number one was
public key cryptography basically it was
the privacy part of it and I'll read it
to you topic establishing secure
communications between separate secure
sites over an insecure communication
link that's exactly public key
cryptography and with the professor
wrote project to much more mundane I
didn't bother listing it look looks more
reasonable maybe because your
description of project one is muddled
terribly talk to me about this about
these today
what did Ralph do he dropped the course
and he women did public key cryptography
on his own unfortunately his paper was
published after ours for reasons that
you'll see even though it's submitted
before ours the C ACM which is a great
journal usually in this case made a
horrible mistake they initially rejected
Ralph's paper the editor wrote I was
particularly bothered by the fact that
there are no references to the
literature has anyone else ever
investigated this approach what's the
answer no this was a seminal paper it's
unusual now admittedly Ralph should have
had some references anyway he was
remember he was an undergraduate when he
wrote this maybe of just beginning
master's student he didn't know how to
write a paper and he didn't have any
real support at Berkeley one of the the
I think it was only one reviewer for
this paper that the editor quoted and
she called him an experienced
cryptography expert and he wrote the
paper is not in the mainstream of
present cryptic cut cryptography
thinking I would not recommend that it
be published ok so let's move on let me
see where I am yeah doing ok John Gill
just went emeritus and yeah last month
in electrical engineering he came as a
new assistant professor night I came in
71 on the faculty I'd done my graduate
work here 66 to 68 came back after a
stint on the East Coast and John came on
a year after me he done his PhD at
Berkeley under Manuel Blum who's now at
Carnegie Mellon and he did it in
mathematics not computer science so John
was a much better mathematician than I
and so when I was looking for structured
cryptographic entities I went to John is
to see if he had any suggestions I
started with the simplest entity a
one-way function so I said John do you
know any functions that are easy to
compute but hard to invert well the
first one our newly the first one that
he told us I forget the conversation was
factoring you know it's easy to find two
large primes multiply them together hard
to factor instead of saying hey we
that's RSA what did I say
I said we've already thought of that and
we haven't been able to do anything with
it
we totally missed our essay after one or
two others he said what about indices
and I said what's an index well he's a
mathematician we call them discrete
logarithms he calls them indices and you
discrete exponentiation y equal alpha to
the X mod Q is fast if you want to
compute alpha to the 9th power you don't
have to multiply alpha times alpha times
alpha 8 or 9 times depending how you
count it you just square alpha 3 times
each of which is a multiplication
getting alpha to the 8th multiplied by
alpha to the first that you already have
and you get alpha to the 9th in the same
way if Q is a thousand bit number you
don't have to do two to the thousandth
multiplications to get the result you
just have to do at most two thousand a
thousand squarings and a thousand
multiplications depending on the binary
decomposition of X and each time you're
reducing mod Q so the numbers don't get
bigger and bigger and bigger there they
stay a thousand bit numbers on the other
hand computing X from Y it's the index
or discrete log is believed to be very
slow although great progress has been
made when John first suggested this to
me the best that we could see was we're
methods that were exponential in the
size of Q whereas now we know
sub-exponential methods now the first
thing I tried doing with this index or
discrete log function was creating a
conventional cryptographic system and I
not sure but I think at this point we
didn't even have the public key concept
if we had we might have we might have
come up with RSA because the system I
came up with was RSA except for one
minor little glitch that you switch that
you see in a minute so I was playing
around one night and I said ok let's
assume that let's look at computing
three different entities you have alpha
x and y if you know alpha NX computing Y
is easy that's exponentiation if you
know alpha and Y competing X is hard
it's a one-way function and then there
was the third possibility if you know X
and y computing alpha I won't show you
how to do it but it's easy
well then I said if you're trying I was
trying to make this into a conventional
cryptographic system I said if you know
the plaintext and the key computing in
the cipher text is easy and ciphering
second line computing the plaintext from
the ciphertext and the key is
deciphering that also has to be easy but
going from the plaintext and the cipher
text to the key has to be hard that's
crypt analysis under what's called a
known plaintext attack and so you've got
easy hard easy and here you've got easy
easy hard what stands out there's only
one hard in both places so K would have
to be X and so that gave me the the
solution which is shown here and that's
Steve poling a couple of years after we
we came up with these results
unfortunately Steve died just last April
in his early to mid 60's great tragedy
but that was in better times the system
was wet the ciphertext B the plaintext
to the K power mod Q that's an
exponentiation that's easy
what deciphering be an exponentiation
also take the ciphertext raise it to the
dthe power mod Q now since I wish to I
do have it sit you substituting P to the
K in here for C you get P to the K D so
what you want is KD must equal 1 right
well except exponentiation in the
exponent is not done mod Q it's done mod
Q minus 1 for reasons we won't go into
it's known as euler's totient function
but that's easy to do it's easy using a
generalized Euclid's algorithm to invert
to find the multiplicative inverse of K
mod Q minus 1 now compare this star say
those of you who know it what's the only
difference instead of mod Q you do it
mod n and instead of calling the
incising key K they call it E and the
deciphering exponent they still called D
now the reason I think we there are
several reasons we missed it I mean we
just missed it but the other thing is I
think I came up with this when before we
had the idea of a public key
cryptosystem and they never came back to
it adequately and looked at it later so
here's the Rs
a public-key cryptosystem almost the
same equations except the north
arithmetic and the exponent is now not
done mod Q minus 1 but it's done mod P
minus 1 times Q minus 1 and that's what
makes it into a public-key cryptosystem
because now knowing the modulus n does
not tell you the factorization and 2 P
and Q so it doesn't tell you it doesn't
tell you what fee event is you need to
know the factorization event to compute
the deciphering exponent from the
enciphering exponent now the polling
Kelman paper appeared a few months after
RSA but was submitted about a year
before it so you have to watch it just
because paper and just like Ralph's
paper appeared after whit's in my paper
but it was actually submitted before it
so there's RSA back in those of you know
Ron today he looks roughly the same but
again just like me older though that's
Adi Shamir on the Left Ron in the middle
and Len Adleman on the right well let me
show you the how to do the what's often
called diffie-hellman but I call
diffie-hellman merkel public key
distribution which was the key the
important well the the the one of the
main results of new direction in new
directions I was playing around one
night with the discrete exponential
function y equal alpha to the X mod Q
but now we have a whole bunch of users
so each user has the secret key and a
public key and so I said let's see why I
equal alpha to the X I mod Q that's the
function and in a minute you'll see how
I came up with the idea to let K IJ the
key that users I and J you so I would
use a different key with Carl from with
Howard because I'd use Howard's public
key and my secret key to get our mutual
key ID used Carl's public key and my
secret key what would Howard do he'd use
my public key in his secret key it turns
out it doesn't matter who does it first
whether you take Y I to the XJ or YJ to
the X I it doesn't matter whose public
key and whose secret key use
get the same result because the result
is alpha to the xixj it's commutative it
doesn't the multiplication and the
exponent doesn't matter which way you go
first alpha to the X jxi is the same as
alpha to the Exide times XJ the
interesting thing is I was trying to
find a public-key cryptosystem because
by this time Witt and I had the concept
but we didn't have an implementation and
yet what I came up with when I did this
was a public key distribution system a
Merkle system so how did I do it late
one night in May 1976 probably after
midnight I was sitting at my desk and I
wrote down the one way function and I
said let alpha and Q be public now
that's important because there are many
variations I mean as I show it to you
here you can see why this is kind of a
trapdoor derivation I already knew that
alpha I know now that alpha and Q should
be public but it that was just one of
many variations I tried that night
computing Y from X is easy computing X
from Y is hard so I tried letting X I be
user eyes secret key and why I being his
public key then what
well eventually I tried why I to the X J
equal Y J to the X I which is alpha to
the X I XJ which I call K IJ my Q and
voila
I had it by the way I had an HP 45
calculator I didn't trust my
paper-and-pencil so I actually
programmed it up and and and did a
calculation to make sure it worked out
okay let's shift and go to unsung hero
number 4 Richard Shaw pal when RSA wrote
their original MIT report and sent me a
draft it suggested using 256 bit modulus
for n I wrote back to Ron and said I
think you need to increase the modulus
eyes because hope L has a factoring
algorithm that by the end of the year he
expects to factor f8 a 256 bit number he
thought he could factor 256 bit numbers
in general so they changed the report to
recommend at least 200 digits in their
famous C ACM paper
by the way the reason our paper appeared
in November 76 and the RSA paper
appeared only months after they
submitted it I was one of the reviewers
for the RSA paper I get a letter from
the editor of the one of the editors of
the C ACM please review this as quickly
as possible this may be the most
important paper we ever publish you
rarely get letters like that from
editors very different from the what
Ralph's got now how many of you have
heard of show pal before how many of you
have not yeah that's what I thought how
many of you heard of how many of you who
have not heard of show pal have heard of
Pomerance is quadratic sieve oh so few
Pomerance is quadratic sieve the
inspiration for it in Pomerantz his own
words were repels work repel didn't
publish but he sent yeah he didn't like
to he doesn't like to for some reason
but he did send copies of his paper
around to me Don Knuth and so you'll see
references and Canoe one of Knuth
volumes to show Paul's work and he's
must have sent it to Pomerance as well
and Pomerance is quadratic sieve is very
similar to I mean sorry it's different
but it's very has you see a lot of
similarity to what rich was doing the
key thing was that rich was able to use
a sieve to double the size of the
numbers that could be factored rich also
came up with the analysis that showed
the e to the square root of 2 e to the
square root of log n log log and
behavior that we now apply to Pomerance
is quadratic sieve rich was the first to
come up with that not rigorously and
other people have since made it more
rigorous another unsung hero Loren Khan
Felder how many of you have heard of him
okay well one person warren was an
undergraduate at MIT doing a bachelors
thesis under one Adelman's direction and
in his thesis he proposed digital
certificates the basis of a whole part
of a whole you know the public key
infrastructure and revocation and things
like that
Loren Khan Felder so Verisign should
give him a cut okay let me shift gears
and let me see where I am on time yeah
better move it up March 1975 wood and I
were waiting we knew that the NBS was
going to
a proposed data encryption standard
finally March 75 it comes out one of the
things we notice is that as if it has a
56 bit key size and we look at that
actually wit was the first one to
recognize he looks he says that's not
big enough I mean that's a hundred
thousand million million keys to order a
magnitude it seems huge to me but wit
said no I think you can do an exhaustive
search I mean what was much more
computer literate than I and basically
what we eventually came up with is you
could search a million keys per second
per chip you buy a million of these
chips at $10 each that's not too
expensive for a place like NSA or their
foreign equivalents that's ten million
dollars whoops didn't help I didn't do
something there
now you're searching ten to the twelfth
keys per second how long does it take to
search 10 to the 17th keys just ten to
the fifth seconds which is about a day
days a little over 80,000 seconds and so
we estimated 10,000 dollars per solution
and worse with Moore's law we estimated
that the cost would decrease by a factor
of 10 every five years for at least the
next 10 20 years which in fact has
happened and worse this is the most
computationally intensive way to break a
crypto system what if there are
shortcuts well n BS answered our other
objections but this one they kind of
glossed over and after six months of
trial thinking this was a bug we
realized there was a feature January
1976 we reserved this is now about six
to nine months after the initial and out
nine months after the initial
announcement six months after we
initially contacted n BS with our
comments and we realize we had a
political problem and if we were going
to change the key size we had to go to
Congress and try to get hearings if we
had to go to the media and get coverage
and we prepared to do that at that time
to high-level NSA employees flew out
they were very friendly not threatening
but they did tell us because they're
trying to get us to quiet down and they
told us that if you continue talking
this way you're going to cause grave
harm to national security well I went
home to try to figure out the right
thing to do that night
my intellect is telling me the right
thing to do is go public the United
States is the most computerized nation
in the world the Soviet Union our main
adversary at the time was the one of the
least computerized we had a lot more to
lose than them there are a number of
other reasons but here I had to high
level and I say people telling me just
the opposite so while I'm trying to
figure out the right thing to do an idea
pops into my head forget about what's
right and wrong
you never have a greater chance to gain
notoriety run with it and I liken it to
the movies where a devil appears on the
actor's shoulder and is whispering in
his ear that was the devil whispering in
my ear at the time I thought I very
correctly brushed that devil off my
shoulder and made a logical rational
decision that going forward was the best
thing now I was right admiral inman
who's the director of NSA at the time in
an interview several years ago that
Henry Corrigan Gibbs a PhD student of
Dan Bonas conducted Henry asked admiral
inman with what you now know would you
still try to suppress Hellmann's work
and Inman said quite the opposite I
tried to get it out as quickly as
possible because the Chinese theft of
Defense related information from the
United States has convinced me that the
national security importance of the
national security importance of strong
commercial encryption so we made the
right decision but I made it for the
wrong reasons
five years later and I won't go into the
details I'm watching a documentary about
the making of the atom bomb and I
realize that I'd fooled myself because I
think the people who worked on the bomb
fooled themselves in a way that's
described I think it's in the C ACM
paper certainly in the book my wife and
I wrote and I what I did was I did what
most people do so I don't fault myself
for this this is a very human behavior I
figured out what I wanted to do which
was go public and then I came up with
the rationalizations for doing it
whether was the right thing or not and
fortune in this case I made the right
decision but if it had been making a
bomb that could destroy civilization I
might have done that too so I vowed
never to do that again now five years
there's another story I know it's in the
book it may be in the C ACM paper about
five years later we're in a patent fight
with RSA Stanford MIT RSA and and silent
and RSA sold their company for 250
million dollars and we made almost no
money off our patents because among
other things they weren't willing to pay
us royalties and the stories in there
and I was really pissed
and by the way Ron's a good friend now
Jim bids ohs who was the CEO of RSA is a
good friend we're past all that I
actually have gone back into my own mind
seen how from their perspective they
could I don't know for sure but they
could see me as having started the whole
fight I don't have time to go into that
in the talk so I'm not blaming them for
this but at the time I was really pissed
at them and the CEO of siling comes to
me and his exact words were you helped
me get an exclusive license to
Stanford's patents and we'll get those
RSA bastards by the balls he spoke that
way he was a little scrappy guy from
Philadelphia and I wanted to it seemed
like it made good business sense to go
with silent but I was afraid that I was
making fooling myself again I went to my
wife and explain my conundrum because I
vowed never to do that again and she
came up with a very simple solution she
said director of technology licensing at
Stanford then was Neils riemer's has the
same business interests that I do and
for Stanford yes he doesn't have the
emotional investment than this that I
did no he didn't let him make the
decision and he said we should go with
silence so I can be sure that I didn't
fool myself that time may 76 we ko
so the DST controversy became even more
important because in May 76 when we
published the diffie-hellman Merkel key
exchange all of a sudden people can
change keys every day every minute if
they want to whereas before was very
expensive they might use keys for years
July 77 a man named Jay a Meier wrote a
letter to the I Triple E this is when
the whole fight kind of came to a head
he was an our Tripoli member he writes
from his home address which happened to
be in Maryland
Witt later confirmed that he worked at
NSA
and he said as an I Tripoli member I'm
concerned that the I Triple E is
breaking the law by publishing certain
papers and he sent a copy of the ITAR
the international traffic in arms
regulations which on the surface may
have said that we could not publish our
papers and international journals
because we were exporting technical
information related to an implement of
war anything cryptographic was deemed to
be an implement of war by the ITAR the I
Triple E wrote back it's interesting by
the way when people start talking about
cryptography they start talking in code
he never said you shouldn't publish
Hellmann's papers but he listed like six
journal or issues that had papers that
he felt violated the law I think I had
papers in five of the six the I Triple E
writes back to him that they are well
aware of the ITAR but it's always been
their position that they cannot be the
gatekeeper it's up to the authors and
their institutions to make sure they're
not breaking the law now in code they
also sent a copy to me but they didn't
send it to me as Martin Hellman author
of the problem some problematic papers
they sent it to me because I was on the
board of governors of the I Triple E
information theory group that was
publishing most of these papers but they
didn't send it to all the governors so I
took the letter to I took the letter to
John Schwartz who was then Stanford's
general counsel because Stanford was
potentially liable and also from a
personal point of view if I was
prosecuted I wanted to make sure I had
Stanford's financial backing because
defending yourself can bankrupt you in
fact you might not even have enough
money probably I didn't have enough
money to defend myself so I had a good
meeting with John and he said after
studying it he said it's his legal
opinion that if the ITAR are construed
broadly enough to cover my papers then
they were it was unconstitutional
because freedom of speech freedom of the
press but he also told me and his letter
is memo in which he put this down is on
the Stanford library archives you can
find it there or I can point you to it
I had them scan all this stuff
he wrote but there's at least one other
one different legal opinion that of je
Meyer and this can only be settled in a
court of law if I was prosecuted they
would defend me if I was convicted
they'd appeal but then he warned me by
the way if you're all appeals are
exhausted we can't go to jail for you
but with Stanford's financial backing I
felt comfortable he also recommended
that to students
Steve Pollock who you saw and Ralph
Merkle who I've also seen who were
slated to give papers joint papers that
we had at the octo in October at the I
Triple E in international symposium on
information theory at Cornell University
he recommended that I give the papers
instead of the students I'd originally
planned for the students to give the
papers because there was a question of
whether the university could defend a
student so be careful you guys
but I was an agent of the University I
was bringing contract grant money into
the university they could clearly defend
me but even more importantly he pointed
out that a new PhD might have trouble
getting a job if he had a multi-year
court case hanging over his head whereas
I was a tenured associate or full
professor at that time so I could my
career was different so I went to Ralph
and Steve and I said told them you know
I feel comfortable giving the papers
with Stanford's backing but whatever you
want to do is fine with me the two
students both said no we'll get the
papers until a week later they come back
and said our parents are beating on us
and actually my mother had called me too
and said what the hell are you doing you
know taking on NSA and so they said
reluctantly we'll let you give the paper
but what I did was when it was time for
these two papers one after the other I
went up with the student and everybody
knew about this legal brouhaha and I
said on the advice of Stanford's counsel
I will be giving the paper instead of
the student but the student deserves
credit as first author I want you to
consider the words that I'm saying as if
they're coming from the student except
legally and of course the students got
more more credit more attention this way
than they ever would
if there hadn't been this going on what
okay the revolution resolution begins
1978 so the year after the Cornell mess
I get a call from the directors office
at NSA admiral inman who was then the
director is going to be on the west
coast he if you're up to it he'd like to
visit with you and we've been fighting
this all out in the press never really
talking directly Meyer wrote his letter
to the I Triple E from his home address
I said great I'd love to talk and so
Inman came to my office a couple weeks
later it was over in the Duran building
on the first floor where they were doing
renovation over they may still be doing
it and his first words practically were
he looked at me and he said it's nice to
see you don't have horns that's how I
was being depicted within the agency and
actually even after we resolved this
there was still people writing things
that have since come out that were
secret now Declassified where they're
calling me all kinds of names I wrote to
him and about and said could you do
anything about this but they really
can't I would back it in then and said
same here because I had seen NSA
actually I pictured them as Darth Vader
and I was younger than I was you know
roughly 30 instead of 72 and I so I
could see myself as Luke Skywalker to
their Darth Vader
he also said I'm meeting with you
against the advice of all the other
senior people at the agency but I don't
see the harm in talking inman is an
out-of-the-box kind of guy you'll see
this from him in general I don't we
don't agree on everything but we found a
lot that we agree on and that was
initially a cautious relationship but
over time it grew actually into a
friendship and I had lunch with him and
when I was in Austin a couple of years
ago and as a good example that it's
better to have friends than enemies I
mean we all know that but how many of us
tried to turn enemies into friends the
way Inman did and it's really nice that
Inman was the one who initiated this
rather than me I give him the credit for
starting this now I tried to do that but
back then it was him about
years ago I realized that one of the key
missing ingredients in nuclear
deterrence was knowing how risky it was
I mean if we could expect nuclear
deterrence to work for a hundred million
years before it failed that's comparable
to an extinction-level asteroid hitting
the earth the fact that we're making
slow progress is probably okay
but if the expected time until nuclear
deterrence fails when we destroy
civilization is more like a hundred
years which in my own research indicates
it probably is that's one percent a year
ten percent a decade the younger people
in the audience not people like me have
probably worse than 50/50 odds of living
out their lives without there being a
major nuclear war that's horrendous well
I wanted people with national security
backgrounds to sign a statement of
support because I'm an electrical
engineer not a former director of NSA
Inman signed the statement of support
now he wouldn't have signed it if he
didn't agree but he also wouldn't have
signed it if he didn't trust me if we
were enemies rather than friends so it's
better to have friends than enemies and
yet how often do we have enemies that we
don't think about how to putt try to
turn them into friends I don't see the
harm in talking my wife and I summarized
this in our book is get curious not
furious that's how we turned a marriage
which started out great fifty almost
fifty-one years ago to the point we were
practically headed probably headed for
divorce ten years later - we're back
where it is now where we haven't had a
an argument in over 15 years I mean we
disagree but we see it as oh why do you
think that that's different for me and
and there's a even a story in the book
the new car story which I won't go into
here resolution grows that started in 78
1993 Congress request the National
Research Council the research arm of the
National Academies to do a study of
national cryptographic policy
particularly export restrictions on
cryptographic devices that was a big
piece of it and the reports called the
crisis report cryptography role in
securing the information society it's
freely available with a PDF on the NRC
or National Academy website all
constituencies were represented I
represented the privacy interest
we had a former director knee general
benjamin civiletti representing law
enforcement the FBI
we had an Kara Christie who is a former
deputy director of the NSA representing
their interests and we put aside our
prejudices I worked really hard at doing
this and they did too and we were able
to reach unanimous conclusions we
compromised a bit we said what's
possible and these were some of our
major conclusions relaxation whoops
export restrictions should be relaxed
considerably in particular des should be
almost freely exportable with a few
exceptions like North Korea and within a
year or two that came to be now we can't
say for sure that our report caused it
but we think it played a role another
conclusion that was in our report that
some people have told me may have been
the most important conclusion is that
the classified information was largely
irrelevant
I had studiously avoided taking
intelligence clearances up to this point
because then NSA would can might be able
to control what I published but I was
getting ready to retire and I wasn't it
didn't anticipate doing research in this
area so I went and took a lie detector
test and all that stuff and got my
intelligence clearance and most of the
committee was cleared we did have some
unclassified briefings because not
everybody was queered
and in those unclassified briefings
several times people said what I'm sure
you've heard if you knew what I knew
you'd think differently well what we
concluded is no I mean the classified
information was somewhat useful but it
didn't really change our overall
perspective in fact I remember saying
look the terrorists have tried to blow
up the world traits in and once
they're gonna try again they're likely
to try again we should be watching for
that this was before September 11th
obviously and so you don't need an
intelligence Korins to be able to see
the really important things we also owe
key escrow was a big piece of the puzzle
at that time too because it's now called
exceptional access and identify three
crypto Wars the first crypto war was
largely over freedom to publish DES key
size things like that and Henry Corrigan
Gibbs article covers that beautifully
which you can find it's on the in the
Stanford alumni magazine freely
available on
line ii crypto war was largely over key
escrow which is today very similar to
exceptional access and our committee
spent the wasted a lot of time trying to
figure out how to do key escrow because
just like today the government had not
put forward the law enforcement and in
that case also national security
interest had not put forward a complete
plan it was just a vague idea that we
should do key escrow without saying how
you'd handle it internationally and a
bunch of other things and at some point
our committee decided was spending too
much time on this trying to figure out
how it would work let them figure out
how it would work and come back to us
and that's what we suggested in the
report they never came back
and I believe that this third crypto war
is really the second crypto war
revisited and you can see that several
former directors of NSA have said that
the FBI is wrong to want this
exceptional access it's really the FBI
that's fighting the third crypto war and
so I think we need to go back and look
at the lessons we learned in the 90s
well in summary this talk has been about
the evolution of public key cryptography
but it also shows personal evolution I'm
not the same person today that I was
when I pictured NSA as Darth Vader when
it took admiral inman to start the
reconciliation process today I try to do
those things and I think this is really
key not only to leading a better life
but to survival of the human species
because unless we learn to get curious
instead of furious we're gonna keep
getting into Wars when we get into more
North Korea and by the way the situation
with North Korea is very different from
what most people think their record
their track record of adherence to the
major nuclear agreement we had with them
known as the 1994 agreed framework is
actually surprisingly good they stopped
building two large reactors under that
agreement we was they were supposed to
get replacement reactors that were more
proliferation resistant from us they
never got them and they couldn't finish
the the partially completed ones because
they'd rusted so badly so they actually
feel suckered by us and Soto arsons
right that North Korea has a bad track
record in some ways and it needs to earn
a place at the negotiating table what he
leaves out is the u.s. also needs to
earn a place at the negotiating table
so there's a lot more involved here than
just cryptography or learning to live
with your spouse or significant other or
your coworkers and so I'd summarize by
concluding get curious not furious and
really work hard at turning enemies into
friends in fact not seeing this paper
you and the two students all have
concerns expressed by your respective
parents well in my case in my case we've
got David Kahn's right Whitney I got
David calm we need to write an op-ed in
the New York Times about the key size
and there's a lot of coverage I mean I
had reporters in my office I could have
spent my full workweek just talking to
reporters and and and film crews
although I didn't and so there was a lot
of news surrounding this I mean the
picture I showed you of Ralph's wit and
me that was in Time magazine so my
mother couldn't help but know that was
going on and the case of Steve and Ralph
I don't know for sure but I suspect you
know they were talking on a regular
basis and and they didn't hide it from
them another question let's see what
take one on this side of the room
anybody yes Carl thank you very much for
a wonderful lecture and all the great
work you've done in this area
particularly in the early crypto Wars
but I'm afraid that we're whelmed in the
third crypto war and they're very
confident now that they can make highly
secure backdoor systems and they're even
proposals brought in Brevard running
like the one that I published in the SSR
Ram and so I don't know what we're going
to do but that seems to be the public
awareness is one of our best defenses
because now that we're gonna help always
be wearing all of glasses in ten years
it's gonna be we see and hear everything
you see here and say and we don't want
that yeah well public awareness is the
key on all these things I just attended
a talk with meeting with Ted Koppel he
has a book out lights out which is about
the potential of a cyber attack on the
electric grid that could fry
transformers potentially and put the us
into a year-long blackout with horrible
consequences now that is an extreme view
but it's we don't know if it's possible
or not I mean look what happened just in
January Paul Carter and several other
people made public their their attacks
on the on the Intel chip that had been
there for years that no one knew about
and this is one of the things that
concerns it concerns me although I have
to consult Dan Bowen at Paul cots your
people like that
because they are much more current and
they agree that when you build in any
kind of exceptional access you build in
all kinds of new possible wormholes that
you couldn't possibly envision so it's
it there's a danger in doing it now
there's a trade-off one other thing I
would have said and this was true back
in the 90s the FBI keeps saying they
want to go back to the good old days
when they got a warrant they could put a
pin in the wire and tap and hear what
was being said well in the in the good
old days they didn't have cell phones
telling them where everybody was they
didn't have the internet where with lots
of unencrypted traffic they didn't have
license plate automated license plate
readers they didn't have security
cameras all over the place many of them
private and when there's a crime very
often though they can go to the owner of
the store and say could I have your
security tape and they'll usually say
yes so roughly speaking let's assume
that law enforcement gets a hundred
times as much raw information as they
got before even if half of it was
encrypted which I doubt they'd still be
getting fifty times as much
informational information as
they got in the good old days and so I
sympathize with them I mean when there
is a criminal act or a potential
terrorist act where they can't get into
a phone they can't get into a
communication I wish they could but we
have to look at the trade-off involved
yes so I should say wedding planning
smart comings in I'm the CTO of our
Kestrel networks and I can I and I'm
really impressed by the transition
you've made to think about yes so it's
somewhat ironic that I left
cybersecurity to work on nuclear
security which is intimately related to
war and peace because the reason North
Korea has nuclear weapons is because
they feel so threatened by us and the
reason they want ICBMs that can reach
our homeland is to deter because as long
as it's over there we we as a nation
don't seem that concern that Seoul would
be devastated in a second Korean War
it's ironic that cyber warfare may in
the not-so-distant future rival nuclear
warfare in its in its consequences but
even if it doesn't do that it can be the
catalyst that weeds to it so absolutely
and so sometimes I say it's not just in
the nuke when I talk about I have a
paper called rethinking national
security which is also on that my
publication space it's a draft paper and
it starts off with the observation that
in 1945 the American homeland could not
be touched
today seventy-three years later
trillions of dollars later we can be
destroyed in under an hour
it seems like something went wrong in
mathematics we have an expression for
this when you when a logical line of
reasoning produces an absurd conclusion
we call it a reductio ad absurdum
reduction to the absurd and it's
surefire proof that at least one
assumption was false now here there may
be other explanations but it also says
we ought to
the assumptions and I start with the
very first assumption that national
security in the nuclear age in the cyber
age in the way age of bio weapons
chemical weapons nuclear security may
becoming obsolete as a concept separate
from global security yet we still
operate as if the way we get national
security is to have more weapons than
anybody else and threaten them or I
actually argue in that same paper that
maybe we should treat not every nation
with the respect it would deserve as if
it already had nuclear weapons so that
we don't encourage them to build them to
get that respect please
so in the 1516 hundreds and early
seventeen hundred's European powers
actually created and allowed to be
created pilot groups the idea was your
Pirates would attack your enemy
privateers yeah and the privateers and
what we're seeing now is privateer Oh
privateer cyber warfare exactly yeah
it just made been some patriotic people
that I couldn't stop kind of a small
footnote instead of reduce this isn't
for severity of piracy was house piracy
we're all getting damage damage to us
all is greater than if we just agreed
not to do this anymore so we need to
order the experiment if we'd we as a
nation would look at the experimental
data when was the last war we had with a
good outcome World War two if you can
call that a good outcome and even World
War two we've been avoidable
there's someone asked me this question
many years ago said how could we stop
world war two non-violent he can't stop
it well without violence because I was
arguing for resolving conflicts without
violence neither physical or verbal and
so I went back and thought about it if
we'd started in 1919 at the Treaty of
Versailles we might well have stopped
Hitler he might never have come to power
but it was that ego that
and was in the part of Britain in France
more than the United States but we
should have stood up to that and if we
look at the experimental data just like
with piracy it wasn't working well
Iraq has not worked out well our
national Security's been hurt by it Isis
had no territory in Iraq under Saddam
Hussein two thirds actually this was
maybe five years ago there was an
article that 2/3 of the Christian
population of Iraq who survived
reasonably well under Saddam Hussein has
had to emigrate out of fear for their
lives the people of Iraq are worse off
our national Security's worse off and
yet we then went under a democratic
administration so it's a bipartisan
problem and attacked Libya now we didn't
have troops on the ground but we created
the conditions that went to chaos and
the murder of Gaddafi and the one of the
ironic things is this last presidential
election was so close that Hillary might
have won if it hadn't been for one or
another of those various press problems
that she had one of them was Benghazi
then God knows I see that as I think
that's totally ginned up as an anti
Hillary thing but some people over away
from Hillary Benghazi never would have
happened if Gaddafi was in charge and
ironically Hillary was the member of the
Obama administration argued most
vociferously for attacking Libya and why
now taking it up to the current regime
change didn't work well in Iraq it
didn't work well in Libya and what makes
us think it's going to work better in
Syria and yet we're saying Assad has to
go now maybe there's something I haven't
heard but I haven't heard anything that
says it's going to be different yes your
name okay so the corporate chip was the
main one of the main as key escrow tech
techniques of the 90s it was a custom
chip that NSA it had a proprietor I
remember had a proprietary NSA algorithm
that was hidden it was on there it
couldn't be a reverse engineer but it
also had every time a message went out
the key that was being used for that
conversation was encrypted under
a chip specific key and the period in
the header so if law enforcement or
national security could obtain the
master key hopefully legally through a
warrant then they could get to that
conversation but the hope one of the big
problems we saw with key escrow in our
committee our National Research Council
committee was what happens
internationally if it's all us
communications fine but what if it's a
French person talking to an American
person who holds the master key and
they're just a number of problems there
do you have any comments on corporate
chip yeah it sounded good and actually I
thought about it yeah at the time
remember des was not exportable to
almost anywhere there was only a year or
two later than once and I remember
thinking well which would I rather have
be true that nobody has strong
encryption or we have strong encryption
but it could be read by the government
and clearly rather have the latter than
the former so it was a step forward in a
way but there was an even better step
which was to make des relatively
explorable it's kind of ironic that des
today is considered is insecure I mean
it still is the big step work they at
the time of our committee 40 big keys
were what works portable not 56 bits and
that's a huge difference yeah thank you
for your talk I was just wondering what
you feel about current floor scale
private key infrastructures related to
cryptocurrency do you think
cryptocurrency has a model what time
does it
[Music]
okay anyway don't worry we won't be and
if I 45 will actually break in
cryptocurrencies I don't own any crypto
currencies I would be very loathe to
invest in them because partly because I
haven't studied them enough now people
like Marc Andreessen who were very
clever have invested in these things the
short answer is I really don't know does
anybody here know anything about
cryptocurrency and so I mean the other
thing is they look into this batman cox
wasn't sure I mean so even if but still
do yes it's still honey how do you work
it and I mean the other big problem is
from what I've heard is people who are
technically clever can handle the keys
and all that so this was for crypto
currencies I really don't know nothing
about it to comment intelligent back in
the room speak up loudly I guess key
escrow hasn't been sort of well fleshed
out in terms of sort of factional
actionable proposals right do you
consider something like like iCloud
where
you know I give my private key Apple Tim
Cook keeps it on us servers for US
citizens
Chinese servers for Chinese citizens etc
do you see that as a form of key escrow
and where it's going because it seems to
me that it matches up pretty well
so the government holding the key is one
of the things we recognized in our
committee 20 over 20 years ago was that
there was a lot of key escrow going on
companies would often escrow keys
because if you encrypted your hard drive
with the key and you died or you left
the company and we're mad at the company
they would want to gain access so
companies instituting key escrow for
themselves were one thing having the
government do it for everyone seemed to
be something else
the other thing since one other thing
that relates here we see what we saw was
that mandated key escrow where there's
going to be a created a took something
that was cheap and easy to do which is
encrypt and made it hard and expensive
like if you become the key escrow
authority are you liable if you divulge
my key either advert you know either
intentionally or otherwise
who's got how much insurance that you're
gonna have to buy and who's going to pay
for that so it took something that was
cheap and made it expensive now if a
company wants to do key escrow for
itself and if people are going to trust
Apple that's one thing maybe there
should be more disclosure so people know
that's what's going on and the
government track record on keeping stuff
secret oh the government track record on
keeping secrets is not so good with you
thinking of the Office of Personnel
Management - what it was called with all
their malware oh and then the NSA now
we're getting out a new proof I gave it
to you that's true max I want to come
back to NSA malware getting out one of
the problems with cyber warfare and
cyber weapons is unlike nuclear weapons
where just knowing that they're possible
doesn't tell you how to make them with
Stuxnet once we used it we or the
Israelis or both used it on Iran they
could take it apart and there's evidence
that they then used to get very
versions of that against Aramco and
[Music]
caused horrible damage and we need to do
the other thing with rushing medley in
American elections we never talk about
America meddling in Russian elections
the Russians are convinced that we threw
the 1996 re-election of Yeltsin to
Yeltsin and what is known for sure is
that American political consultants were
helping Yeltsin's campaign and another
thing it's a little bit suspicious and
actually I have more than suspicions I
have evidence that the US Congress vote
on additional sanctions on Iran was
delayed until after rouhani was elected
the moderate the more moderate because
if we put those sanctions in before the
election it would have given extra so we
meddle in elections all the time
oh and on the grid we're worried about
other people attacking our grid there
was an article in The New York Times
which doesn't make it true
but it's it lends some credence to it
that that I came across when I was
getting ready to go to Ted Koppel's
meeting and this was during the Obama
administration that it said that America
had cyber weapons ready to attack the
Iranian electric grid if we couldn't get
them to agree to the agreement that was
that was reached and Trump is now trying
to kill I saw a student with a question
yeah so you worked on all these really
good questions so how do I decide how do
I end up working on all these important
problems I'm a world-class fool I
there's my lecture there's electron wine
on YouTube stamp with engineering school
zero lectures so to Google Stanford
engineering here on helman you'll
probably find it it was on the wisdom of
foolishness and so I'll tell you a
little story here about 25 maybe 30
years ago my wife was doing tarot cards
and I went to her why doing Tarot I mean
we don't believe in that kind of crap
and but I wasn't fully curious but I was
a little curious that I didn't get
which I might have done 10 years earlier
and she said well I was afraid of Tyrell
but she pick up in our culture because
the church made taro in anything
mystical that was out of the church evil
of the devil and she said I was afraid
of Tyrell and I decided if I was gonna
be afraid of it I should know what it is
I mean she's amazing this way and so she
said would you like me to do utero
reading so she wasn't putting a lot of
stock in it but she thought it was
interesting so she does make cards and I
end up being the fool and my first
reaction is I'm no fool I'm a Stanford
professor look what I've done and but
then she pointed out the positive
qualities of The Fool he goes where no
one else goes in the fool card he has
one foot on the on the ground and one
foot off and he's blindfolded going off
a cliff but the party's gonna be okay
he's got a little dog following very
cheerfully and in that moment I realized
it came to me that I had done the work I
had done because I was willing to appear
foolish and so watch that lecture if you
want to see the long version of the
wisdom the foolishness and I have quotes
from half a dozen it could have I could
have made two dozen colleagues who have
won major awards who also were seen as
foolish Vint Cerf is when you all
recognize he said that even after the
success of the ARPANET people thought
packet switching was crazy for voice
much less video and of course that's how
we get Netflix today what do I think of
the progress being made on quantum
computers so I always have to ask my
friends who know something about quantum
computing and I haven't asked recently
but several years ago when I asked
someone and probably in instan lab or
whatever they call it these days
he said that we won't know for at least
10 years if quantum computing is a
realistic threat to public key
cryptography was like thousand 2000 bit
modulus because they'd have to build at
least thousand or two thousand cubic
quantum computers and he said if it
becomes a potential threat let's say ten
years from now we'll probably have at
least 10 years before it actually is
implemented but I've given talks
in which I point out that there's
another threat to public key
cryptography and that's a major advance
in factoring there were major advances
in factoring in 1970 Morrison Brill
hearts continued fraction method factor
def 77th Vermont number 120 if it's long
now it's a major advance then repeal or
Pomerance is sitting roughly ten years
later could do 256 big numbers in fact
to double the size of the numbers have
changed it from e to the square even the
square root of two log and Waka again to
e to the square root of log n log log n
and the log log n is not that important
so it was the two that went away it
roughly doubled the size of the numbers
you could factor 1990 roughly ten years
later we get it the number field sieve
which not only it doesn't just cut a
factor of two in the exponent two
changes it to either the cubed root of
log n log n that's really dangerous
because now another major advance that
cut that to eat to the cube root of log
n over two or something like that
could blow the size of the numbers that
we need up to 10,000 bits or something
unusable
now most people tend to look at it and
say but we haven't had a major advance
in factoring in almost 30 years since
roughly 1990 it looks like factorings
hit a brick wall but I look at it
differently and my work on nuclear risk
analysis of nuclear deterrence comes in
here many people have said look 73 years
without a world war don't worry but I
will get in safe you have a coin of
unknown bias that you toss 73 times and
get 73 tails in a row meaning no nuclear
war how confident can you be of not
getting ahead in the next hundred years
which is roughly the life expectancy of
a child born today 90 years next call
not very confident and in fact if you
want a 95 percent confidence in your
prediction you can only predict a third
of 73 years so whatever that is less
than 25 24 years into the future if you
want to be 50 percent confident you
could predict roughly 73 years into the
future in the same way I look at each
decade as a heads if there's a major
advance in factoring in tails if there
isn't roughly speaking and going
assuming no major advance in fact
occurs by 2020 we've seen heads heads
heads that was continued fractions
sitting and number field sieve tails
tails probably tails if you saw a coin
toss six times the choke heads heads
heads tails tails tails would you say
heads is not likely to occur ever again
no no that's an imperfect model but it
does indicate that you shouldn't we
shouldn't have a lot of confidence so I
think we need to also worry about
advances in factoring and so post
quantum public key cryptography or post
quantum cryptography and post next
advancement quad cryptography might very
well be very similar and I made some
proposals like using and again I'm not
as current as other people but knowing
what I know from twenty thirty years ago
we might use key distribution centers
which are not as good as public key
cryptography but they can distribute
keys for privacy along with public key
cryptography and then you XOR the two
keys together
if either method stays secure you're
secure and so put this in place now
before there's a major advance in
factoring because this could happen that
could happen overnight and you suddenly
find our whole digital economy coming to
a standstill for signatures rap Merkel's
true signature method combined with one
of the digital signature algorithm
methods so you sign a message twice and
either method secure then you're at
least one signatures doing five it's
5:45 so let's break where people can
leave will stick around for another
you